We had a viewer write into us
about a piece of old furniture that needs a bit of a revamp.
Take a look at Dana, the school teacher.
(drum music)
Hi, my name is Dana.
I'm a teacher in New York city.
And this,
right behind me is our cat jungle gym/entertainment unit
/my ex-husband's childhood bedroom set.
It's actually four pieces of furniture.
It's a dresser, a little kid's desk
and two hutches all shoved together
to be one giant entertainment unit
for my new marriage
and my new life.
I am thankful that my ex-husband left me,
with this massive amount of furniture
but I would kind of like a fresh start.
Thank you so much for revamping my furniture.
Please come revamp my furniture.
Thank you.
(crowd laughing)
Oh, Dana.
These are the kind of things we love to tackle here.
Hi, Dana.
Hi, Drew.
How are you?
First of all, I'm fantastic
and I love your story.
Well, thank you so much, Drew.
I love being here.
I just love your whole spirit and energy and attitude.
And I also think that this is a really fun thing to tackle.
Is there any way in which you would like us
to transform this furniture?
Do you have any goals in your mind, any vision
or is it all up to us?
For sure, Drew.
Well, I will leave it up to you
but I think we'd love just a fresh start
so it matches kind of our decor.
It would be great
if it was functional for Murphy and Monster, our cats
because I think they pretty much use that furniture
more than we do.
Mhmm.
So if it would reflect their style,
that would be pretty cool for us.
Okay. All right.
Well, we called in some backup to help give your furniture
some new life.
And right before the show,
DIY expert from the popular blog, A.V. Does What,
A.V. Perkins got to look at your dresser
and she's currently backstage doing the whole thing.
But, and this is gonna be hard for me
because we're gonna have to wait
till the end of the show for the big reveal
and gosh, Dana
I hope you're liking what A.V. is gonna do.
Thank you so much.
Good luck A.V., I appreciate you.
Well, I just so excited
because for me, I love re-imagining things myself
but I can't wait to see what A.V. does with this.
I'm hoping she's gonna show me something
I even wouldn't have imagined.
So.
Yeah.
All right.
I think it's gonna be great.
Go Dana, go A.V.
A.V., this looks great.
Are you ready to bring Dana to the show
and take a look?
I am so ready.
She's, she's gonna be blown away.
I'm ready.
Dana, are you there?
I am.
Hi Drew, Hi A.V.
Thank you.
Okay. A.V. can you walk Dana through what you did?
Okay. So, first what I did was I removed the hardware.
You know, out with the old in with new.
I feel like her rugs really go well with these,
with these tall poles.
Yes
This are gorgeous knobs.
I love so much.
It's just enough pop of color to add the razzle dazzle.
I also,
(Dana laughing)
created this cat spot.
So there is a cat bed,
there is a scratch pad.
And there is a mobile
that they can kind of just play with and relax
when, you know, when they're not on the highway
(A.V. chuckling)
I love it.
Murphy and Monster's Highway
Yes.
And I love the ball of yarn.
And this
Yeah, so they can play.
beautiful baskets you brought in.
I mean, it's really joyful.
Yup. And then I, you know, used some wallpaper here
and I used it here just to keep making, you know, cohesive
and bring some newness to this piece.
Well, I think you did.
Dana, what do you think?
Oh, it looks so fresh and awesome
but it really only matters what Monster thinks and Murphy.
And I think he's the real.
It looks so great A.V.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I love the letters.
I love the way the wallpaper makes it look super modern
and not like kids' bedroom furniture.
It's really fresh.
Umm and Dana, I wanted to ask you quickly
about your "Got Your Vax" initiative.
Will you tell us about it?
Yes sure, Drew.
I was so excited in January,
at the beginning of January,
I found out I was eligible as a teacher in New York
and I got my vaccine super early and it felt great.
And so I wanted to pay it forward
and I started helping other people making
their vaccine appointments.
And now here we are a couple of months later.
I have a group of friends.
They're all called "Vaxlenteers".
All doing the hard work of making people appointments.
I personally have made over 1200 appointments for people
'cause it's really hard.
(crowd cheering)
Oh my God Dana.
That's great heights.
That's amazing.
Thank you.
I can't believe how much you've accomplished.
And Dana, we're gonna send this back to you
with also a thousand dollars
(crowd cheering)
just to (indistinct)
your vaccine initiative,
in anyway, you know, that you see fit.
And A.V. thank you so much
for revamping this for Dana.
(crowd cheering)
No problem.
Thank you so much.
We'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)